Hilary Clinton says the FBI's directors
reopening of her email investigation is
one reason why she was not elected
president the former Democratic
candidate spoke yesterday and a women's
rights conference President Trump
responded on Twitter that Comey was
quote the best thing that ever happened
to Hillary Clinton he also claimed the
Trump Russia story was an excuse used by
the Democrats as justification for
losing the election Nancy Cordes looks
at Clinton's latest reaction to her
defeat Nancy good morning good morning
Clinton said she took some personal
responsibility for her loss but she
didn't really elaborate on what she or
her campaign could have done better she
did go into detail about the other
factors she says led to her defeat I
highly recommend long walks in the woods
it is far healthier than screaming at
your television set Clinton did not
reflect on her failed bid at a gala
celebrating Planned Parenthood you know
if the election meant on October 27th
I'd be your president but earlier in the
day she spoke candidly saying her
victory was derailed by forces out of
her control it wasn't a perfect campaign
there is no such thing but I was on the
way to winning until the combination of
Jim Comey's letter on October 28th and
Russian WikiLeaks raised doubts in the
minds of people who were inclined to
vote for me but got scared off Clinton
also found fault in the presidential
debates which she said focused too much
on personality I was waiting for the
moment when one of the people asking the
questions would have said well so
exactly how are you going to create more
jobs right I mean I I thought that it
you know I thought at some moment that
would happen but that moment did happen
more than once please explain to me why
you believe that your plan will create
more jobs and growth for this country
and your opponents plan will not in this
round you go for a Secretary Clinton the
former Secretary of State mocked the man
who beat her for attempting
international diplomacy via Twitter
negotiations are critical but they have
to be part of a broader strategy not
just thrown out on a tweet some morning
that hey let's get together and you know
see if we can't get along and maybe we
can you know come up with some part of a
deal
that doesn't work Clinton did say she
supports President Trump's decision to
launch airstrikes in Syria last month
but beyond that she had little praise
and even described herself Gayle as part
of the resistance movement that has
erupted in reaction to his presidency
all right thank you very much Nancy more
to come from Hillary Clinton it seems